so
today's topic is a little bit ambitious
today i want to talk about
everything you need to know before you
start a career in architecture maybe
you're in high school or you're in a
different field thinking of going into
architecture school
hopefully this video will give you some
insights into the profession and the
industry and teach you some things that
they don't really tell you when you
start architecture school
[Music]
hey guys how's it going
welcome back to the channel
if you're new here my name is dami and
i'm an architect in vancouver and so
i've
condensed it down into five themes
and
obviously
it's kind of an ambitious video i don't
think i can really cover everything that
you need to know but these are really
the basics so that you can decide for
yourself whether it's worth it for you
to
go into this incredibly long difficult
endeavor so architecture is
it's
so fun architecture school is really fun
you are
problem solving you're researching
you're designing you're communicating
you're presenting
you're making so all these things are
things that i love and
i wouldn't give up my ears in school for
anything but there are a lot of people
who
went into the field
thinking that it was something
completely different and so hopefully
this video will give you some insights
into what it's really like
after school what it's really like
working in the field so that you can
make an informed decision on your career
path
[Music]
so there's a really big difference
between a project that you do in school
and projects that you do in real life
and the first one will be the scale
real projects take
years and years
to complete
and
because the timeline is stretched out
over many years
you might spend an entire year just
doing one phase of the project
so your day-to-day
in an office
is not going to look like
what you're doing in school because you
might get stuck doing construction
documents you might be detailing a wall
you might get put on construction
administration
or you might get put on schematic
design and
that timeline has just stretched out
that your day-to-day as an architect
might not necessarily have those
creative aspects that you experience in
school
in school everything is condensed into
one semester
so
you might be doing research for a couple
of weeks and then you might be
designing for a couple of weeks
you might be making things for a couple
of weeks and then you're presenting
every day you're doing something kind of
different
and
design is always a big aspect of your
everyday in real life it's
less of that there's more coordination
there's more talking to consultants and
clients in the city and because the
scale of the project is so much bigger
you're going to be put on a team
so it's not going to be you doing your
own project unless
you're a sole proprietor and
you're doing small ti's or small
residential buildings usually you'll be
put on a team and you'll be working with
other architects other designers you'll
be working with other consultants
and it's really a team effort
in school it's really about your project
your baby and you learn a very different
set of skills when you're working
the second big difference is the
complexity of the project so buildings
are very complex we are constantly
getting energy upgrades uh we're
always coming up with new products so
what that means is that
you're gonna have to constantly learn
about new systems
and that you will have a team of
engineers
working with you and helping you
figure out your building and so a big
part of your job is actually
coordinating with the engineers
and making sure that what they design
aligns with the overall design of the
building so for example you have an
exposed ceiling and the mechanical
engineer put in
work going from one part of the room to
another you're responsible for making
sure that that duct work doesn't collide
with a light that you put in
or that it's not sticking into a wall
it's your job to make sure that all
these components line up together
in a pleasing and functional way
and the third big difference is that
real life projects are much more
pragmatic
and have more
constraints you don't really choose the
program the program is chosen for you
maybe by the developer or the client so
let's say that you're given ten thousand
dollars to do schematic design so that
means that you divide that by your
hourly rate which will give you the
number of hours you're supposed to spend
on time i think a lot of architects go
over budget because we love to
make good buildings in regards to the
construction budget
just keep in mind that
like everything that you design
it has to have some return on investment
unless you're designing like a house for
a millionaire
and so you can't really go on and design
all these
open public spaces because that space
isn't really generating any income right
so you want to make the spaces as
functional and pragmatic as possible and
try to add in your
creative design
within those parameters as you go on in
the design process
you might be working with a cost
estimator or you might have
someone who can do that within your firm
but you're going to be constantly
adjusting your design based on the
budget
and whenever the client wants to cut
something
oftentimes it's going to be because of
budget concerns
because buildings nowadays are so
complex it's common for architects to
specialize in a specific building type
or in a specific role in an architecture
firm
so a building type could be like
residential
um
swimming pools institutional buildings
towers and so this is going to determine
your career path and what type of firm
you want to be in the smaller the
project the more you can do it by
yourself
which means you'll be involved in all
the different phases of the project
for example you will be meeting with
clients you'll be doing the schematic
designs you'll be doing the programming
you'll be developing the massing of the
building the look of the building and
you'll be doing the construction details
and you'll be doing the construction
administration because it's small enough
it's easy enough
for one or two people to manage
by themselves
and then the bigger the project
the chances are you'll be involved in a
team of people so depends on what kind
of workflow you like depends on what
kind of environment you like to work in
and also depends on what type of project
you're into
you can also specialize in a different
area within architecture
so you can become
a project architect or a project manager
you can become a design architect
someone who
just does the schematics and the design
development and figures out the massing
of the building and the look of the
building
you can
specialize in construction documents you
can specialize in construction
administration
and these roles are a little bit more
relevant in bigger firms
because it's more efficient for that one
person to be doing
the thing that they're good at
instead of switching different roles
a little bit down your career you're
going to have to decide whether you want
to work for yourself
or you want to continue working at a
firm once you get your license you are
basically
capable of working for yourself and
stamping your own drawings right
as long as you get your certificate of
practice and your insurance you can
basically open up your own practice but
i think less and less people are doing
that now because
you know it's it's so hard to
have your own practice and work for
yourself but there are some really great
benefits to working for yourself you can
be involved in all phases of project
you're doing your own marketing you're
going out and getting the clients you're
dealing with the clients you're doing
the design you're doing the drawings you
might be getting help from an intern or
a freelancer but you're in charge of
everything but essentially you're the
one who's running the show and the other
good thing is that you can keep all the
money that you're making
you know if you are a sole proprietor
you will probably have lower overhead
you're not getting a salary you're
you're billing your clients per hour if
you decide to do that there's a lot of
things other than
architecture that you have to be
concerned about like
administration
legal stuff finance
so if you are not interested in
doing that stuff then maybe that is not
the path for you
and then of course there's the path of
working for a firm
and there's so many benefits to that as
well
i think if you work by yourself you
won't get access to so many different
project types
as working for a firm if you work for a
firm you might one day be doing
residential you might be doing
institutional or you might be doing a
tower if your firm is set up that way
and you'll be working with a team of
people
and
i think working for yourself can be very
isolating because if you have problems
you don't really have anyone that you
can talk to if you want to celebrate you
can't really celebrate with anyone
so it can be
harder
for some people
but you have full control over
everything that you do so it really
depends on
your work preferences you can also work
first architect
and i think that's the path that a lot
of students just out of school want to
take
because those are the architects that we
learn about in school and
um i've never worked for a star
architect before so i don't i can't i
couldn't really tell you but i have
heard some
stories i think
a common scenario is that you're getting
paid very very little money because
there's a
huge amount of students who are just
willing to do that that's something that
you will have to consider
so to get licensed in canada you'll have
to do 3 700 hours
and that is broken down into site
schematic design
development
coordination construction admin
instruction admin site
project management
construction documentation
in a lot of cases it can be hard to hit
all those hours especially if you go
into a big firm
and sometimes you might have to switch
firms to get those hours in canada you
have to take your exacts which is
the equivalent of a bar for architects
and
in the states you take your ares and the
difference is that in canada it happens
once a year
and you take all the four sections all
at once
and in the states the sections are split
into
i think they do it like once every
couple months
so if you fail one section you can just
take it again in a couple of months and
you can
subdivide your studying into different
sections there's for some reason a lot
of people who will tell you that it's
not worth getting licensed
but that has definitely not been my
experience
you can just bring so much value to a
firm by being a licensed architect first
of all they can bill your time at a
higher rate just by understanding all
the project phases it means that you can
be
a more valuable contribution to your
team
and if you decide to leave the standard
traditional architecture firm and
work for a construction company or a
developer or an interior design firm
it means that you can be the one who's
stamping the drawings
and
i think in a lot of cases these days
clients or the city they want a
certified professional to stamp the
drawings
so that's very valuable for them so
my advice would be just to get licensed
as fast as possible
and then the last one is money
so you're not gonna get as much money as
someone who just finished six years of
schooling
for example a lawyer i think is a common
comparison because schools don't really
prepare you to be
valuable at a firm right from the get-go
you really have to learn
in the firm
how to work in the industry so
you know that's
i don't know some people say that
that's how it should be i think it's a
failure of the education system
but yeah just remember that
to learn to be a real life working
architect you need to do your internship
at a firm and if you want to increase
your starting pay
you can do co-ops or work during the
summer so that you can
over time just
get more of that practical knowledge
and then you can start off at a slightly
higher salary and i would just say
strategize early on in your career
my advice would be to get your license
as soon as possible because
that can make a big difference if you
are working for an architecture firm
it's not likely that you're going to be
stamping your own drawings but you will
still bring a lot of value to the
company but yeah those are some of the
things to keep in mind and getting your
license or just studying for your
license exams means that
you're getting yourself familiar with
all the different phases of the project
and so um before you get your license
i think you should moonlight i think you
should
try to just work for yourself
and i think it teaches you skills that
you don't necessarily learn working in a
firm because
you
learn to work with clients and you learn
to manage their expectations
and you learn the value of your time
you learn
how to negotiate which i think are all
really really critical skills i hope you
found that helpful if you kind of want
to go through this point by point just
go to my blog and you'll find it in
written format this is a topic i've
gotten a lot of questions about
and
[Music]
it was taking me a really long time to
type out my answers every single time
because there are so many things that
you should consider before you
uh
start a path in architecture
and so i i hope you guys found this
video helpful
and i hope i didn't sound too jaded in
my video
but
um
let me know if you have any questions um
i will gladly answer them
if you haven't already please subscribe
and
give me a thumbs up
and i'll see you in the next video we'll
give you some insights into the field
and into the profession
[Music]
[Music]
you